sagen sie uns welche regeln ganz kurz
mal beschrieben für all die menschen die
jetzt den gang zur urne heute noch vor
sich haben muss man unbedingt einhalten
damit dass nichts schief geht ja wie
heute eindrucksvoll belegt hat ist das
wahlgeheimnis eine ganz ganz wichtige
regel das heißt auf keinen fall mit dem
ehegatten in die wahlurne gehen das ist
ein absolutes no-go auch fertig machen
in der wahlkabine das sollte man
vermeiden also wo die erste regel das
wahlgeheimnis ganz hohes gut deutsche
eingehalten werden jetzt die ganz
konkrete situation dort in aachen
beschrieben der unions kanzlerkandidat
der sich so gut mit dem wählen und
gewählt werden auskennen sollte wie
eigentlich kein anderer in deutschland
der geht heute wählen denn aachen füllt
alles offenbar anständig aus seiner
sicht zumindest macht die beiden kreuze
bei seiner partei und dann faltet er
diesen wahlzettel aber nicht richtig und
zwar so dass man nämlich seine
stimmabgabe sieht also wie beurteilen
sie diesen vorgang
der bundeswehr schreibt ganz ganz klar
vor dass man eben den stimmbruch halten
muss dass man gerade die stimmen nicht
lied die bundeswahl ordnung wie die es
dann auch so dass der wahlvorstand da
noch mal die pflicht einzuschreiten
falls das eben mal anders läuft das wäre
an sich das mal kein problem gewesen der
wahlvorstand hätte einschreiten müssen
herr lacher täter einfach noch mal
wählen müssen aber ähnlich wie das auch
schon gesagt wurde würde ich auch sagen
da führt nicht zur ungültigkeit der
stimme denn auch dass statt des
bundeswahlgesetzes ganz klar vorwand
stimmen ungültig ja und da ist so eine
geschichte wie falsch gefüllter
aufgefüllte oder holz gefallen
verwalteten eben nicht erwähnt
was könnte das jetzt wirklich für
konsequenzen haben mit einigen experten
bereits gesprochen das wäre sozusagen
buchwitz bin ich weg und statt mir ist
frau berghoff da ist es aber auch schon
der ist nämlich gerade auf
glaube ich ganz kurz darauf gehen auf
das bild aber vielleicht können wir
patricia einfach wieder hin zu holen und
bei aber auch gerne eine aktuelle beta
aber sehen aber dann habe ich natürlich
gleich nur aufgehen wenn frau berbalk
dann im wahllokal ist so genannten ob
sie den wahlschein richtig faltet aber
sie hat auch lieber noch ein paar peter
ist für ihn platz zwei und so jetzt aber
meine frage was könnte denn im
schlimmsten fall passieren wenn man das
jetzt einmal alles durchdekliniert
welches regelwerk ist da gibt es könnte
im schlimmsten fall jetzt passieren
könnten falls sich die strafrechtliche
konsequenzen denn verletzung des
wahlgeheimnisses das ist ein
straftatbestand
er wird unter juristen diskutiert ob man
denn überhaupt selbst verwirklichen kann
also wenn ich selber sozusagen meine
stimme ist zeige aber gerade der
bundeswahlleiter der hat mich in der
vergangenheit sehr entschieden dazu
geäußert hat gesagt ja das kann ich auch
selber machen eben gegen sozusagen die
geheime wahl verstoßen auch wenn ich
meinen stimmen verteile dann kann das
eben ein straftatbestand sein
jetzt ist es ganz ganz oft dass es nach
einer wahl in einzelnen regionen
beschwerden gibt anfechtungen gibt von
der wahl in diesem fall laschet ist
davon auszugehen dass irgendwas kommt
wenn es da ganz knapp stehen sollte in
diesem wahlkreis und insgesamt bei der
wahl heute abend das wenige tausend
stimmen möglicherweisen entscheiden wie
würde man dann mit diesem fall umgehen
im nachhinein ich glaube das würde ich
nicht ändern letztendlich hilft auch
wirklich das gesetz ganz klare regelung
man hätte es anders machen müssen der
wahlvorstand hätte hier einschreiten
müssen aber die konsequenz dass damit
die stimme ungültig ist das sehe ich
nicht dafür fehlt eben an der
rechtlichen grundlage das
bundeswahlgesetz hat ganz klar
vorgegeben wahnsinn stimmen ungültig und
dazu zählt eben einfach nicht der falsch
gefaltete
sie sprachen gerade von einem
straftatbestand welche strafen drohen
denn dann im zweifel armin laschet zwei
jahre freiheitsstrafe ist das häufig
nicht drin wobei man sagen muss da ist
von 80 die rede und es ist tatsächlich
umstritten ob man eben welt diese
straftat begehen kann oder ob jemand
anders nur meine stimme öffentlich
machen muss das war auch bei anderen
vergangenen bundestagswahl schon immer
wieder diskutiert die entsprechenden
strafanzeigen wurden davon der
staatsanwaltschaft mit dieser begründung
eingestellt interessant ist eben
eigentlich dass der bundeswahlleiter
hier gesagt hat ich kann es durchaus
selber machen indem ich meine stimme
öffentlich mache darf ich eben gegen
diesen straftatbestand verstoße
[Musik]